10 Disney Stars Who Are Not As Innocent As
They Seemed
Disney has an incredible history of recognizing
talent at a young age and putting those young
stars front and center in their shows and
movies.
Many of these child stars fade off in to obscurity
and many of them have a hard time ever shaking
off their early Disney roles.
For this video we are taking a look at the
Disney stars who grew up to be far less innocent
than we once thought with our list of 10 Disney
Stars Who Are Not As Innocent As They Seemed.
Enjoy this video and be sure to subscribe
to Screen Rant for more great content, every
single day.
Zac Efron
Zac Efron’s career was jumpstarted by the
major success of the Disney Channel original
movie, High School Musical.
In the musical movie (and its two sequels),
Efron plays Troy Bolton, the leading man who
can sing, dance and play basketball.
With his success in the movies and his boyish
good looks, girls of all ages were falling
madly in love with him.
Fast-forward a decade and while Zac may still
have the killer looks, he has traded in his
adorable Disney star appeal for a more crude
masculine look.
It only makes sense that Efron would start
choosing racier roles as he got older and
we are sure that his fans weren’t complaining
when they got to see a lot of his ripped body
in Neighbors and Dirty Grandpa.
Look out for Efron in 2017’s Baywatch movie
where he will be yet again playing the role
of eye candy.
Shia Labouef
At this point, we aren’t even sure what
to refer to Shia Labouef as any more.
The guy has been the subject of some pretty
weird Internet videos, some freestyle rap
battles, some box offices hits and some really
bizarre art films.
It’s pretty crazy to see where Shia is today
when you take a look back at his humble beginnings
as the star of the Disney Channel show, Even
Steven’s.
Shia was such a fun and energetic young actor
and as soon as he finished up on the Disney
show he started landing roles in movies like
Disturbia and The Transformers franchise.
Since then, he has sort of gone off the rails
having made some very strange public appearances
and some very racy movies like 2014’s Nymphomaniac.
It’s hard to tell if Labouef is in trouble
or just having a good time doing whatever
he wants, but we hope all the best for him
either way.
Miley Cyrus
There was a time when Miley Cyrus was legitimately
the biggest Disney channel star on the planet.
Her show, Hannah Montana was a massive hit
and also did a great job of transitioning
the young actress into a full-fledged career
as a singer.
Once her show ended, Miley decided to shake
the Hannah Montana persona and work as Miley
Cyrus full time.
The singer started making more mature music
and produced more sexually explicit music
videos and these days she is no stranger to
flaunting her body in the nude.
Miley may be considered crazy by some but
the truth is, she is very confident as the
self assured woman that she is and we are
happy for all her success.
Demi Lovato
Just like Selena Gomez, Demi Lovato got her
start very young as a nerdy looking kid on
Barney and Friends.
Lovato then got her big break as the star
of the Disney Channel movie, Camp Rock.
Her success in this movie, along with her
relationship with Joe Jonas helped to skyrocket
her career as a performer and she eventually
decided to pursue a career in singing full
time.
While Demi has definitely found a lot of musical
success in the last few years, things weren’t
always so easy.
Lovato has spoken publically about her struggles
with an eating disorder and she has also spent
time in rehab for drug use.
The good news is that she has used these experiences
to fuel her recent success, but she is definitely
not the innocent little Disney star she once
was.
Nick Jonas
Before the days of Justin Bieber and One Direction,
The Jonas Brothers were the boy band that
had teenage girls all over the world falling
in love with them.
While all three brothers starred in their
Disney channel show, it became more and more
clear that Nick was going to branch off and
be a star on his own.
After seemingly disappearing for a few years,
Nick Jonas has returned to the spotlight with
a very different image.
The 24 year old star is now making some pretty
sensual music and he is not shy to strip down
for a racy photo shoot every once and a while.
Nick Jonas has definitely successfully shaken
off his innocent Disney child star image and
it looks like he has a bright future ahead
of him.
Britney Spears
Wait, what Disney show was Britney Spears
on?
If you answered The Suite Life Of Zach and
Cody, you clearly need to brush up on your
Disney knowledge.
The world famous pop star was never on a Disney
show but she was a member of the infamous
Disney Mickey Mouse Club alongside Ryan Gosling,
Justin Timberlake and Christina Aguilera.
Although Spears has probably achieved the
most success out of anyone on this list, she
has also probably hit the lowest lows.
Take your pick, from public melt downs, to
leaked sex tapes to multiple messy public
divorces, Britney Spears has been through
it all.
The craziest part of it all, however, is that
Spears has made it through all of this and
has continued making music and achieving worldwide
success.
Vanessa Hudgens
After seeing Vanessa Hudgens play Gabriella
Montez, the female lead opposite Zac Efron
in the High School Musical movies, it seemed
like she was destined for glory.
Hudgens was a classic Disney triple threat
with the ability to act, sing and dance but
somehow she seemed to get left behind while
all of the other stars around her rose up.
We’re not sure why this is, but it definitely
didn’t help her cause when a number of nude
photos of her were leaked online.
We feel bad saying it, but it definitely tarnished
her image and then her choice to star in the
famously racy flic, Spring Breakers, seemingly
sealed her fate.
Hudgens is only 28 and she has landed herself
a lead role on the new show, Powerless, so
we will keep our fingers crossed that she
can finally figure it all out.
Anne Hathaway
When you’re thinking of young Disney stars,
Anne Hathaway probably isn’t the person
that comes to mind first.
However, Hathaway actually got her start in
2001 when she starred in the Disney-made movie,
The Princess Diaries.
This movie was a big hit and Hathaway was
instantly pegged as a safe and innocent young
starlet.
It took a while for Hathaway to shake this
‘nice girl’ persona and to start showcasing
her deeper talents.
In 2010, she let to world know she was no
longer the young innocent girl by baring it
all and performing some pretty wild sex scenes
with Jake Gyllenhaal in Love and Other Drugs.
It seems like this decision worked as Hathaway
was able to take home an Academy Award a few
years later for person gritty performance
in Les Miserables.
Lindsay Lohan
When it comes to stories of child stars crashing
and burning, Lindsay Lohan is at the top of
almost every list.
Lohan got her start earlier than most as she
was already working as a model at the age
of three.
When she was in her early teens she was the
star of two major Disney movies; The Parents
Trap and Freaky Friday.
Lohan was fantastic in these roles and for
a while there it looked like she was on route
to becoming a huge success story.
Unfortunately, in 2007 her career flew off
the rails when she started racking up multiple
arrests and check-ins to rehabilitation centers.
Lohan’s offences range from driving under
the influence, to drug use and possession
to not being able to comply with her parole
orders.
Lindsay Lohan’s story is a real shame, but
the good news is she is only 30 years old
so there is still hope that she can find some
redemption.
Selena Gomez
Selena Gomez’ career got off to a really
early start when she (alongside Demi Lovato)
was one of the kids on Barney and Friends.
Gomez then moved on to bigger and better things
with her leading role in the hit Disney channel
show, Wizards of Waverly Place.
Selena was great on the show and it was clear
from a very young age that she was going to
be a star.
Since leaving the Disney channel life behind,
Gomez has really started to focus on her music
career and has been pumping out hits for years
now.
Gomez also surprised fans with a shockingly
racy performance in 2012’s Spring Breakers,
a movie known mostly for tainting our memories
of a few Disney stars.
Sprinkle in some racy photo-shoots, a very
public relationship with Justin Bieber and
you get one Disney star that is not as innocent
as she used to be!
So there you have it, there is our list of
10 Disney Stars who are not as innocent as
they used to be.
Which one of these Disney stars was your favorite
when they were young?
What other Disney star stories do you know
about?
Sound off in the comments section below and
be sure to
subscribe to our channel for more fun videos
– like this one!